I do use syntax highlighting, but I'm more and more turned off by syntax highlighting. What? What? You don't like syntax highlighting? Yeah. You sound like an old grumpy man. I mean, I am an on February 5th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we talk about how to get started with C++. New episode. This is going to be episode like 68 or something. Who knows?
我确实使用语法高亮，但我越来越对语法高亮感到反感。什么？什么？你不喜欢语法高亮？对。听起来你像个脾气暴躁的老头。我的意思是，我是——2022年2月5日。我叫康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起聊聊如何开始学习C++。新的一集。这大概是第68期左右的节目。谁知道呢？
This is coming out probably in March of 2022. We had a person. His name, Jeff Erickson. Shout out to Jeff Erickson. Hello, Mr. Erickson. And he sent me a sort of episode request. So Bryce has gotten zero. He's going to be off the cuff responding.
这期节目大概会在2022年3月发布。我们遇到了一位听众。他的名字叫杰夫·埃里克森（Jeff Erickson）。向杰夫·埃里克森致敬。你好，埃里克森先生。他给我们发来了一个节目选题请求。所以布莱斯之前完全不知道。他将即兴做出回应。
But we're going to go ahead and read this message from Jeff Erickson, and then we're going to answer this live. Hey, Connor, Jeff here. I'm a huge fan of your YouTube stuff as well as ADSP. Well, thank you, Jeff. It's kind of you to say so. I wanted to write to say that while sometimes you might think that the audience as ADSP. Well, thank you, Jeff. It's kind of you to say so. I wanted to write to say that while sometimes you might think that the audience of ADSP is a bunch of C++ people
不过我们要先读一下杰夫·埃里克森的这条留言，然后我们会在现场解答。嗨，康纳，我是杰夫。我是你YouTube频道的超级粉丝，也是ADSP的粉丝。好吧，谢谢你，杰夫。你这么说真是太客气了。我想写信说，虽然有时你可能会觉得ADSP的听众……ADSP的粉丝。好吧，谢谢你，杰夫。你这么说真是太客气了。我想写信说，虽然有时你可能会觉得ADSP的听众是一群C++从业者，
who also want to branch out, I think there are also a lot of people like me, that is, people with 10 plus years as an engineer who have never touched C++. Personally, I've worked in Python, R, Go, Perl, and SQL. I've also been interested in functional languages, and I'll be honest that I hadn't given C++ much thought since I've avoided it until now, until I started listening to ADSP. Listen to that, Bryce. We're changing people's views. I love this guy.
他们也想涉猎其他领域，但我认为也有很多像我这样的人，也就是说，有10年以上经验但从未接触过C++的工程师。就我个人而言，我用过Python、R、Go、Perl和SQL。我也对函数式语言感兴趣，说实话，在开始听ADSP之前，我一直都在避开C++，对它也没怎么关注。听到没有，布莱斯？我们在改变人们的观念。我太喜欢这家伙了。
I hear that, Jeff. Bryce loves you. But now, I am C++ curious. So I thought it might be worth suggesting to you to do an episode on ADSP where you talk about why you guys like C++ and talk about how someone without any experience could try it out or get started or inspire. C++ is one of those languages that, to me at least, feels so big and massive that it's extremely intimidating to start learning it as a 35-year-old who isn't learning it in school. What resources would or could get someone's feet wet enough to tell them if they should continue the journey? And also, I think it would be worthwhile to describe your dev tooling also since that too has been a huge black box to me with respect to C++. Maybe it's just the circles we find ourselves in, but I feel that while the newer, cooler languages and quotations get a lot of action in terms of interesting books to read and cool tooling to improve your dev environment, languages like C++ don't seem to get the same
我听到啦，杰夫。布莱斯很喜欢你。但现在，我对C++充满了好奇。所以我想也许值得建议你们在ADSP上做一期节目，谈谈为什么你们喜欢C++，谈谈一个没有任何经验的人如何尝试它、如何上手或者获得启发。在我看来，C++是那种让人感觉极其庞大、极其宏伟的语言，对于一个35岁且不是在学校里学习它的人来说，开始学习它是极具威慑力的。有什么资源能或者可以让人浅尝辄止，从而判断自己是否应该继续这段旅程呢？此外，我觉得顺便介绍一下你们的开发工具也很值得，因为对于C++而言，工具对我也一直是个巨大的黑盒。也许只是我们身处的圈子不同，但我感觉，那些较新、更酷的语言（加引号）在阅读有趣的书籍和改善开发环境的炫酷工具方面得到了很多关注，而像C++这样的语言似乎并没有得到同样的对待。
treatment. As experienced C++ people yourselves, maybe that is less clear to you. If it's not episode worthy, if you could at least maybe give me a few tips for starting points, I'd really appreciate it. Thank you, Jeff. So Jeff, I think it's a great episode idea. And now we're going to get Bryce's response. So the question is, in the midst of that big long message, is that, you know, how does someone get started now that they're C++ curious when they're not learning it in school? Where do you begin? What resources would you recommend? And what about the tooling setup? Bryce, go.
作为经验丰富的C++老兵，你们可能对这一点感触不深。如果这不适合做成一期节目，哪怕能给我一些入门的建议，我也非常感激。谢谢你，杰夫。所以杰夫，我觉得这是一个非常棒的节目创意。现在我们要听听布莱斯的反应。所以问题在于，在那个长篇大论中，就是说，既然现在对C++充满好奇，而又不是在学校里学习，一个人该如何开始呢？从哪里开始学起？你会推荐什么资源？还有工具配置方面呢？布莱斯，请开始。
So let's start off with why I like C++. I think, actually, if you go back, one of our earlier episodes, we talked about how many programming languages should you learn. And I took the position of, you only really need to learn one or two. And Connor took the position of, learn all the programming languages. And I actually think that's one of the nice things about C++ is its versatility. C++ is a multi-paradigm programming language. I think that is really the defining characteristic of C++ as a programming language. That you can, you know, it's an imperative language.
那我们先从我为什么喜欢C++开始讲起。其实，如果你回看我们早期的节目之一，我们谈到了你应该学习多少种编程语言。我的观点是，你其实只需要学一到两种。而康纳的观点是，学习所有的编程语言。其实我认为C++的优点之一就是它的多功能性。C++是一种多范式编程语言。我认为这确实是C++作为编程语言的决定性特征。你可以，你知道的，它是一种命令式语言。
It maps very closely down to hardware. But also it's, you know, an object-oriented language. It's a generic language. It's a functional language. So you can use a wide variety of different programming paradigms and techniques. And I think more importantly, you can combine those different techniques together. And so for me, one of the things that's appealing about C++ is that for systems programming tasks, you can use it for almost anything
它非常贴近底层硬件。但同时它也是，你知道的，一种面向对象的语言。它是一种泛型语言。它是一种函数式语言。因此你可以使用各种各样不同的编程范式和技术。我觉得更重要的是，你可以把这些不同的技术结合起来。所以对我来说，C++吸引人的地方之一在于，对于系统编程任务，你可以用它来做几乎任何事情，
and not be restricted to a particular way of programming. It gives you many different choices and options. You know, sometimes some of those are foot guns, which people don't love. But that to me is a big part of the appeal. Now, it doesn't mean that you can actually only learn C++ because it's, you know, as a sort of a systems programming language, something that you use to write, you know, underlying things. And as a compiled language, it's not, you know, as nimble as something like Python. But if you're in that space of writing, you know, something that needs to, some sort of system software, something that needs to some sort of system software something that needs to be high performance or that that needs to talk to hardware talk to operating systems etc or you know a lot of
而不受限于某种特定的编程方式。它为你提供了许多不同的选择和备选方案。你知道的，有时其中某些是“自伤武器（foot guns）”，人们不太喜欢。但对这我来说，这是它巨大的魅力所在。现在，这并不意味着你真的只能学C++，因为它，你知道的，作为一种系统编程语言，它是用来编写底层东西的。作为一种编译型语言，它没有像Python那样灵活。但如果你身处那个领域，需要编写某种需要具备高性能、或者需要与硬件对话、与操作系统对话等系统软件，或者你知道的，
the meat behind a lot of the things that we actually use end up getting written in C++. And to me, part of the appeal is that, like, you can learn this one skill, how to, like, program in C++, and then there's just a very wide variety of things that you can do with it. So I think to me, that's, like, part of the appeal and the magic of it, especially as compared to other systems programming languages. Yeah, one thing I'll echo, because a lot of the, I like C++ for the same reason. I will say, on a small tangent, once again, at the Denver C++ meetup, which I think got mentioned a couple episodes, the most recent topic was like an open conversation on what makes programming fun. And at one point, I mentioned in the chat that I said, you know, C++ is not fun in parentheses relative to other languages, which was kind of
我们实际使用的许多东西背后的核心内容，最终都是用C++编写的。对我来说，它的部分吸引力在于，你可以学会这一项技能，比如如何在C++中编程，然后你可以用它做各种各样非常广泛的事情。所以我觉得对我来说，这就是它的部分魅力和魔力所在，特别是与其他系统编程语言相比。是的，我要附和这一点，因为很多——我也因为同样的原因喜欢C++。我得说，扯开一个小题，再次提到丹佛C++聚会（Denver C++ Meetup），我想前几期节目里提到过，最近的话题是一场关于“是什么让编程变得有趣”的公开讨论。当时我在聊天里提到过，我说，你知道的，C++相对其他语言而言是不好玩的（加上括号），这其实
just a provocative thing to say because I like APL better. But like the thing that I really like about C++, especially compared to languages like Go, is Go is not programming language enthusiasts' language, meaning that they really want you to do everything sort of one way. Like that's sort of the thing about Go is that they've got sort of one way to do it and all Go code tends to be very, very similar. And so you can hop from one code base to another code base and sort of the tribal knowledge of that sort of code base is very similar. And so you can hop from one code base to another code base. And sort of the
有点挑衅意味，因为我更喜欢APL。但关于C++我真的很喜欢的一点，特别是跟Go这样的语言相比，那就是Go不是那种面向编程语言爱好者的语言，意思是他们真的非常希望你以某种单一的方式做所有事。Go就是这样，他们有一种特定的做事方式，所有的Go代码往往都非常非常相似。所以你可以从一个代码库跳到另一个代码库，这种代码库的部落知识（tribal knowledge）是非常相似的。因此你可以从一个代码库跳到另一个代码库。这种
tribal knowledge of that sort of code base is very small. So you can ramp up extremely quickly. It's a high productivity language. But that means that if there's, you know, there's not a lot of options as a programmer for how you want to do something. Whereas in C++, it's the exact opposite. Like C++... If anything, there's too many options. Exactly. And which, as a programming language enthusiast, I get to choose the style. Do I want to code functionally? Do I want to code, you know, small talk, you know, OO-ishly with messages and, you know, that kind of style.
代码库的部落知识非常少。所以你可以极其迅速地上手。它是一种高生产力的语言。但这意味着，作为程序员，你在如何实现某事方面没有太多的选择余地。而在C++中，情况恰好相反。C++……如果有的话，那就是选项太多了。完全正确。而作为一个编程语言爱好者，我可以选择编程风格。我是想用函数式编程呢？还是想用类似小矮人（Smalltalk）、面向对象那种带消息传递的风格。
Like, you can code in whatever style you want. You want to code, you know, basically with just C with classes, you can do that as well. Which leads to issues if you don't have agreement with your co-workers on like how you want to program yeah it's like one of the reasons why you know coding styles and code guidelines are so important in c++ and i feel like there's some other programming languages where maybe like people who program in those languages like this idea that it's important to have coding styles might be foreign because they're just so used to
你可以用任何你想要的风格编程。如果你只想用带类的C语言（C with classes）来编程，你也可以做到这一点。这就会导致一个问题，如果你和同事在编程方式上没有达成一致，是的，这就是为什么编程风格和代码规范在C++中如此重要的原因之一，我觉得在其他一些编程语言中，可能那些在那些语言中编程的人，会觉得“拥有统一的编程风格很重要”这种想法很陌生，因为他们太习惯于
like this is the way that you write code in this language but in c++ there are many different flavors and that's the whole thing is you know the python ecosystem as well like it's not as much the same as go but they try to layer that you know the zen of python there's one way to write code and, you know, the Zen of Python, there's one way to write code and just, you know, black is the formatter that everyone uses. Python, once again,
这就是这种语言写代码的方式了。但在C++中，有许多不同的风格，这就是全部的重点，你知道的，Python生态系统也是如此，虽然它不像Go那样极端，但他们试图层层加入“Python之禅（Zen of Python）”，即有一种编写代码的标准方式，而且，你知道的，Black是每个人都在使用的格式化工具。Python再次向我们展示了，
they try to sort of like, idiomatic Python, the Zen of Python is like, there's one clear way to do things. Whereas in C++, there's never one clear way to do things. There's like literally C++ 11, 14, 17, 20, the way you're going to do metaprogramming
他们试图将诸如“符合Python习惯的写法（idiomatic Python）”、“Python之禅”之类的理念强加进来，认为做事有一种清晰的方式。而在C++中，永远没有一种唯一清晰的方式。这里简直有C++ 11、14、17、20，你在每个版本中进行元编程的方式
is vastly different in each one of those because we got if constexpr in C++ 17 we got concepts in C++ 20 we got constexpr in C++ 11 and more and more constexpr stuff with every edition like how you do metaprogramming is like drastically different
都有着天壤之别，因为我们在C++ 17中有了`if constexpr`，在C++ 20中有了概念（concepts），在C++ 11中有了`constexpr`，并且随着每一个版本的推出，`constexpr`的东西越来越多——你进行元编程的方式在每一个标准中
in every single standard which is definitely a thing that is intimidating well it's like I used to say this. Mostly I used to say it's about Java. And you know what? I'll shit on Java a little bit. Juicy content. Here we go.
都有着截然不同，这绝对是一件让人感到畏惧的事情。好吧，就像我以前常说的。主要是我以前常说的是关于Java的。你知道吗？我要稍微吐槽一下Java。劲爆内容。我们来啦。
You know, there's bad C++ code out there, but there's also like good C++ code out there. Whereas for a language like Java there's only really mediocre Java code. Shots fired. I myself love all programming languages and I'm not even gonna say even Java I'm just gonna say Java like is included you know there's no even there it's all programming languages get a little heart. Fun fact, when I was at LSU, working like my first six months there before I was a student, when I was just like a college dropout working at the research center, I worked with this professor, Steve Brand. And for reasons that are still beyond me he asked me to substitute teach for his like intro programming course one day and it was he was more of a programming languages guy like you actually
你知道，C++里有糟糕的代码，但也有优秀的C++代码。而对于像Java这样的语言，只有平庸的Java代码。开炮了。我本人热爱所有的编程语言，我甚至不会说“哪怕是Java”，我只会说Java也被包含在内，你知道的，连“哪怕”都没有，所有的编程语言都值得一点爱。有趣的是，当我在路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）时，在我成为学生之前的那头六个月里，当时我只是一个在研究中心工作的大学辍学生，我和一位名叫史蒂夫·布兰德（Steve Brand）的教授一起工作。出于至今仍让我费解的原因，有一天他让我去代上一节他的编程入门课。他其实更像是一个编程语言专家，就像你一样——
we should have him on the podcast sometimes because i just realized that you two are like shockingly similar in your programming language tastes. Although he was like, this was a guy who, if I needed like a script for something, I could email him with a rough description and he would send back like the most obfuscated Perl script that you could imagine. Like no comments, no line breaks, and it would do exactly what I wanted,
我们真该请他来上播客节目，因为我刚刚意识到你们两个人在编程语言的品味上惊人地相似。尽管他是个这样的人：如果我当时需要一个脚本来实现某种功能，我可以发邮件给他一个粗略的描述，他就会回给我一个你能想象到的最晦涩难懂的Perl脚本。没有注释，没有换行符，它能完美实现我想要的功能，
but I'd never know how it worked. But then I substitute taught for this Java class for like one class. I didn't know anything about Java. I'm not like literally, I'd never written a line of Java code in my life, but somehow I got through it. I think the students did not realize that I had never written Java code. I think it was early in the semester, so they were still learning about fundamental data types. And so I just was like, oh, it's like, you know, fundamental data types, they're basically the same in all the languages. I can just teach them. Strings, just plus equal, right? Yeah.
但我永远搞不懂它是怎么运作的。但后来我去代了一堂Java课，就一节课。我对Java一无所知。我不是开玩笑，真的，我这辈子从来没写过一行Java代码，但我居然混过去了。我觉得学生们当时根本没意识到我从来没写过Java代码。我想那是学期刚开始的时候，所以他们还在学习基本数据类型。于是我就想，哦，就像是，你知道的，基本数据类型，在所有语言里基本上都是一样的。我完全可以教他们。字符串嘛，直接用`+=`就行了，对吧？是的。
But that was the one time that I taught a college course. It was an intro to programming I taught a college course. Was an intro to programming class in Java. Yeah. All right. Well, back to Jeff's question. So that's why we like C++, because you can do whatever you want, basically. Yeah.
但那是唯一一次我教大学课程。那是用Java教的一门编程入门课。好吧。那么，回到杰夫的问题。这就是我们喜欢C++的原因，因为你基本上可以随心所欲。是的。
And also, when you compare it to sort of the other – that's actually – he asked a follow-up question if we have thoughts on Rust or C++, but I feel like we should save that for another episode when we bring someone on that actually knows about Rust and then we can go back and forth. So that's why we like C++. What do you recommend for someone that wants to start learning? I get this question a lot. A lot of people ask me about book recommendations, and that's always tough for me because I don't really read programming books. The circumstances that I will read programming books is if like one of my somebody that I know has written a programming book and like I get sent a copy of it. Like then I'll like read it. You know, I saw you tweet about Kate Gregory and Guy Davidson's book the other day. Yeah. And like i've got you
而且，当你把它和其他——这其实是——他紧接着问了一个问题，问我们对Rust或C++有什么看法，但我觉得我们应该把这个留到以后再讨论，等我们请来一个真正懂Rust的人上节目，然后再来回切磋。所以这就是我们为什么喜欢C++。对于想要开始学习的人，你有什么推荐吗？我经常遇到这个问题。很多人向我询问图书推荐，这对我来说总是很难回答，因为我其实并不怎么读编程书籍。我读编程书的情况通常是，比如我认识的某个人写了一本编程书，然后我收到了一本赠书。这种情况下我才会读。你知道的，我前几天看到你在推特上讨论凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）和盖伊·戴维森（Guy Davidson）的书。是的。我有——
know i've read titus's software engineering at google book but that's not really a programming book that's a that's a software engineering book there aren't a lot of those um i'm looking at my shelf here um i've read some of lakos's books um that's john lakos from bloomberg but i don't like me going to read a programming book I guess the only two programming books that I've really ever read have been Elements of Programming and Structure and Interpretation of Computer Programs
你知道的，我读过蒂图斯（Titus）的《Google软件工程》（Software Engineering at Google），但那其实不是一本编程书，那是一本软件工程书。这类书不多，嗯，我看着书架上的书……我读过一些拉科斯（Lakos）的书，那是来自彭博社的约翰·拉科斯（John Lakos），但我不怎么去读编程书。我想我真正读过的唯二两本编程书是《编程元素》（Elements of Programming）和《计算机程序的构造和解释》（Structure and Interpretation of Computer Programs），
and Parts of the Art of Computer Programming Volume 2 and Volume 3 because I only have Volume 2 and Volume 3 as we discussed in an earlier episode I was gifted those by my mentor Hartmut Kaiser and I asked where are the other volumes and he's like you don't really need those. I don't think that that was his real answer.
还有《计算机程序设计艺术》第2卷和第3卷的一部分，因为正如我们在早期的节目中讨论过的那样，我只有第2卷和第3卷，它们是我导师哈特穆特·凯瑟（Hartmut Kaiser）送给我的礼物。我问他其他的卷在哪里，他说你其实不需要那些。我觉得那不是他的真实回答。
I think he just didn't know where they were. But yeah, I've never really been like a book learner. So that's always tough for me. I mean, the way that I, when I started programming, and I think we've discussed this in the podcast before, I wanted to create a text-based game of Mudd. And I was working with this guy and we were writing it in C++. And so he was teaching me a little bit about C++. And then he used one of the Boost algorithms for string splitting. And then it had a bug in it.
我觉得他只是不知道它们在哪里。不过，是的，我从来都不是那种通过看书来学习的人。所以这对我来说总是很难。我的意思是，自我开始编程以来，我想我们在播客里以前也讨论过，当时我想创建一个基于文本的MUD游戏。我和这家伙一起工作，我们用C++编写它。所以他教了我一些关于C++的知识。然后他用了Boost库中的一个字符串分割算法。结果它里面有个Bug。
And I went and fixed the bug. And then I quickly got involved in boost and this was like in like month two or three of me teaching myself to program um so for me like the way that I learn and get started is I just like start like I learn by doing I learn by example um so it's hard for me to recommend learning materials because I have not often used learning materials. I just like to dive right in. I don't know. Do you have books or resources?
我去修复了那个Bug。然后我很快就参与到了Boost项目中，这大概是我自学编程的第二个月或第三个月吧。嗯，所以对我来说，我的学习和入门方式就是直接开始——我在实践中学习，通过例子学习。所以很难让我推荐学习资料，因为我很少使用学习资料。我只是喜欢直接一头扎进去。不知道。你有什么书或者资源推荐吗？
Something more useful than what I just said. I mean, when I really dived into C++, the books that I tore through were Scott Myers books. The effective C++, more effective C++, effective modern C++, and then the effective STL book. I feel like we should publish a book most effective C++. Those are great, although I'm actually not sure
有没有比我刚才说的更有用的东西？我的意思是，当我真正深入学习C++时，我啃过的书是斯科特·迈尔斯（Scott Myers）的书。《Effective C++》、《More Effective C++》、《Effective Modern C++》，还有《Effective STL》。我觉得我们应该出版一本书叫《Most Effective C++》。那些都是好书，虽然我其实并不确定
how they've aged. I think they do actually age quite well, although now that like 17, 20 are out, I'm sure that there's some stuff that's out of date and i would definitely say that uh finding i always try and find a online sort of playground i don't have more effective c++ i only have effective c++ do you have more effective C++? I mean, the one thing I do like about,
它们的年代感如何。我觉得它们其实保鲜得相当好，不过现在随着17、20标准的推出，我确信里面肯定有一些内容已经过时了。我绝对会说，寻找——我总是试图寻找一个在线的游乐场——我没有《More Effective C++》，我只有《Effective C++》。你有《More Effective C++》吗？我的意思是，我确实喜欢的一点是，
I do particularly like effective C++ and more effective C++ because it's a book that's a list of specific things. And like, that's something that I can use. It's like, you give me like a list of like ways to do things. Yeah, I mean, I feel like, I feel like most of this is still pretty applicable. Familiar size, familiarize yourself with the standard library, including TR1.
我特别喜欢《Effective C++》和《More Effective C++》，因为这是一本列出具体事项的书。而且，这是我能用得上的东西。就像是，你给我列出一系列做事的方法。是的，我的意思是，我觉得，我觉得大部分内容依然非常适用。熟悉标准库，包括TR1。
That's less applicable. Familiarize yourself with Boost. Even though I am a Boost person and I start enough with Boost, I feel like that is actually less applicable these days um yeah i don't know how applicable this this book i feel like i feel like effective c plus plus um and a lot of c plus plus books of that era era are much more focused on object-oriented design than on other parts of the language. And at least for me,
这就不太适用了。熟悉Boost。尽管我是一个Boost粉丝，而且我也经常用Boost起步，但我觉得现在这些内容实际上不太适用了。嗯，是的，我不知道这本书的适用性如何。我觉得，我觉得《Effective C++》以及那个时代的很多C++书籍，比起语言的其他部分，更加专注于面向对象的设计。至少对我来说，
it is very rare in my work that questions of the design of inheritance hierarchies or polymorphic objects comes up. Almost always it's questions of library and interface design and with simple or relatively simple vocabulary types. Yeah. So yeah, if you're looking for a book, honestly, I would just Google C c++ 20 there's like five or six c++ 20 books out there so i think i would actually recommend beautiful c++ because it is a book in the style of like for me it's a good book because it's a book in the style of
在我的工作中，关于继承层次结构设计或多态对象的问题是非常罕见的。几乎总是关于库和接口设计的问题，并使用简单或相对简单的词汇类型。是的。所以，是的，如果你在找书，老实说，我建议直接谷歌搜索C++ 20，市面上有大约五六本关于C++ 20的书，所以我其实会推荐《Beautiful C++》，因为这本书的风格——对我来说是一本好书，因为它采用了
effective c++ and that it's like concrete list of, I think it's, hang on, I'll get the copy. 30 core guidelines for writing clean, safe, and fast code. So it's like 30 concrete things that you can learn and like, or like 30 mantras or takeaway lessons. And it's just been published. So it's fairly up to date um yeah and i would say the yeah one of the most useful tools is a compiler explorer which is basically an online uh compiler that you can just go write your c++ code in the browser. And at least while you're learning, unless if the way you're going to start learning is by building some project, I would just sort of code there because it's awesome. Like even half the time when I do development, if I can sandbox it and build up a prototype,
《Effective C++》的风格，包含具体的清单。我想它是——等等，我去拿一本。编写清洁、安全和快速代码的30个核心准则。所以它大约有30个你可以学习的具体事项，或者说30个座右铭或核心收获。而且它刚刚出版。所以相当与时俱进。嗯，而且我会说，是的，最有用的工具之一是编译器资源管理器（Compiler Explorer），它本质上是一个在线的——你可以在浏览器中编写C++代码的编译器。至少在你学习的时候，除非你开始学习的方式是构建某个项目，否则我建议就在那里写代码，因为它太棒了。甚至有半数时候我在进行开发时，如果我可以将其放入沙盒并构建一个原型，
I'll just do it in Godbolt. Yeah, I do find Godbolt to be a very good resource for learning um and i use it a lot day to day because if i just want to go answer a quick question about how does something work in c++ um you know going and doing it on my laptop involves like you know i have to go put a file somewhere then i have to go find a compiler that works. And it's like God Vault, it's just the turnaround time is so much quicker. Yeah. Yeah, I actually, I think I'm going to be bold and say that, you know,
我就会直接在Godbolt上做。是的，我确实发现Godbolt是学习的一个极好资源，
I rarely actually, like, endorse a book because, again, like I don't really read them that much but I really did like beautiful c++ I feel like it's it is a better version of effective or more effective c++ that has like the guidelines and the rules that I would want to have so yeah that one that one has my stamp of approval but I don don't know. I think it's good. I think that sort of book's good if you already know the language and you want to know how to write it good. It's maybe not the best for learning the language.
并且我每天都在使用它，因为如果我只是想去快速回答一个关于C++中某事是如何运作的问题，去我的笔记本电脑上操作涉及——你知道的，我必须把文件放到某个地方，然后我得找一个能工作的编译器。而就像Godbolt，它的周转时间要快得多。是的。是的，我其实，我想我打算大胆地说，
Yeah. Do we want to talk about tooling? Well, I think we just did. We talked about Godbolt. I know, but outside of Compiler Explorer, I would say the way that I develop right now is with VS Code and a bunch of extensions. So Clang Format, Clang Tidy. And you can, I think, I think Jason Turner,
我很少真正地推荐一本书，因为正如我所说，我真的不怎么读它们，但我真的很喜欢《Beautiful C++》。我觉得它是《Effective》或《More Effective C++》的改良版，包含了我想拥有的那些准则和规则。所以，是的，那本得到了我的盖章认可，但我不知道。我觉得它很好。我觉得这类书很适合你已经懂了这门语言、并且想知道如何写好它的时候看。对于学习这门语言来说，它可能不是最好的选择。
I'd probably point you to C++ Weekly because he basically has like a short five to 10 minute video on every topic under the sun. And I'm pretty sure he's got one on claim format he's got one on clang tidy and i think jason turner even has like a little starter cmake project that has all that stuff set up from the get-go i feel like my answer is gonna not be very helpful here um which is that what i use vim i've only ever used vim i started off my career on supercomputers
我们想聊聊工具吗？好吧，我觉得我们刚聊过。我们聊了Godbolt。我知道，但在编译器资源管理器之外，我会说我现在的开发方式是用VS Code加上一堆扩展。比如Clang Format，Clang Tidy。而且你可以，我想，我想杰森·特纳（Jason Turner），
and uh you know when you work in supercomputing you often you have to go and do stuff on some obscure system somewhere that's running like rel like a red hat release that was put out you know before like when you were in high school and there's like no graphical user interface there's no nice things and like you gotta you gotta edit some code there and so you know them is the thing that like you can reliably have on those platforms and or you can easily install um or yourself. Cause I've had to do that many, many a time because the platform had two engine, a version of them for me to work with and it's like lightweight. And I've got a little Vim config that I've built up over the years that mostly
我可能会向你推荐C++周刊（C++ Weekly），因为他基本上为太阳底下的每一个主题都制作了一个简短的5到10分钟的视频。我确信他有一个关于Clang Format的视频，他有一个关于Clang Tidy的视频，而且我觉得杰森·特纳甚至还有一个小型的CMake项目模板，从一开始就把所有这些东西都配置好了。我觉得我的回答在这里可能不太有用，那就是我用Vim。我只用过Vim。我的职业生涯是从超级计算机开始的，
functions and I copy that from system to system and that's what I use for my editor. And like I don't use many Vim features. One of my colleagues, Mihao, has pointed out that like I don't really know how to use Vim. I don't know all of the, like every time I'm screen sharing and I'm using Vim, he like teaches me a new thing and I'm like, wow, that's going to save me so much time. I don't have it like cooked up with any of the so much time. I don't have it cooked up with any of the IDE features. I don't use anything like C tags. I've never used Clang format.
而且，你知道的，当你从事超级计算工作时，你经常需要去某个运行着晦涩系统的奇怪地方做事情，比如运行着红帽（Red Hat）发布版，那个版本发行的时候，你知道的，就像你还在读高中一样。那里没有图形用户界面，没有美好的事物，你得在那里编辑一些代码，所以，你知道的，Vim是那种你可以在这些平台上可靠拥有、或者可以轻松安装的东西。因为我已经这么做过很多很多次了，因为该平台有两个版本的Vim供我使用，而且它很轻量。我有一个多年来建立的小型Vim配置文件，它大部分
I do use syntax highlighting, but I'm more and more turned off by syntax highlighting. What? What? You don't like syntax highlighting? You sound like an old grumpy man. I mean, I like an old grumpy man i mean i am an old grumpy man connor i am an old grumpy man um i mean i i usually i usually use cmake but for a lot of like little projects i just write a bash script that calls the compiler that I need. I mean, my development life is held together by bash scripts. So that's me. Yeah. I have used, I did use recently the, God, what is it? I tweeted
都能正常工作，我把它从一个系统复制到另一个系统，这就是我用于编辑器的工具。而且我不怎么用Vim的许多功能。我的同事米哈奥（Mihao）曾指出，我其实并不会用Vim。我不知道所有的——比如每次我共享屏幕并使用Vim时，他都会教我一个新的技巧，然后我说，哇，这能为我节省那么多时间。我没有把它和任何IDE功能结合起来配置。我不用像C tags这样的东西。我从来没用过Clang Format。
about it. I needed to do a PR just on GitHub. I didn't want to check out anything locally. And I used the online VS Code thingy on GitHub where if you change the starting URL of a link to something on GitHub, it then drops you into this online VS Code developer environment. Isn't it just control period as well the shortcut here let's go try let's go try yeah if i go control dot shift dot yeah shift dot shift setting setting up the web editor yeah yeah it's if you change it from github.com to github.dev, then it drops you in this environment. And I was amazed, listener.
我确实使用语法高亮，但我越来越对语法高亮感到反感。什么？什么？你不喜欢语法高亮？你听起来像个脾气暴躁的老头。我的意思是，我喜欢像个脾气暴躁的老头。我的意思是，我就是一个脾气暴躁的老头，康纳，我是一个脾气暴躁的老头。嗯，我通常——我通常使用CMake，但对于很多小项目，我只写一个调用我需要的编译器的Bash脚本。我的开发生活全靠Bash脚本维系。所以这就是我。是的。我用过，我最近确实用过，天哪，那是什么？我发推特
Like, I was like, I need to make this change where I need to change two files and then, like, submit a PR. And usually, like, on the GitHub website, if you need to change one file and submit a PR, that's easy to do. But if you need to change two files and turn them into a PR, that's tricky. And I was like, I don't want to check this repo out. I have like 10 minutes before I need to leave, but like, I need this change in because like our CI is broken. And I was able to just like, like I didn't do shift dot, but I did like, I just changed the URL from github.com to github.dev.
提到过它。我需要纯粹在GitHub上提交一个PR。我不想在本地检出任何东西。我用了GitHub上的在线VS Code小玩意，如果你把GitHub上某个链接的起始URL改一下，它就会把你丢进这个在线的VS Code开发环境中。快捷键不就是Ctrl+句号吗，在这里，我们去试试，去试试。是的，如果我按Ctrl+点，Shift+点，是的，Shift+点，Shift+点，设置网页编辑器。是的，是的，如果你把`github.com`改成`github.dev`，它就会把你丢进这个环境里。当时我惊呆了，听众们。
It dropped me into this environment. I was like able to open up a branch. I was able to like make my changes and like, it was just amazing how quickly it was done. And I was like, this is how I want to write code now. So yeah. But I only casually use VS Code. My day-to-day go-to editor is Vim.
就像是，我当时想：我需要做这个更改，我需要修改两个文件，然后提交一个PR。通常情况下，在GitHub网站上，如果你需要修改一个文件并提交PR，这很容易做到。但如果你需要修改两个文件并将它们变成一个PR，这就很棘手了。当时我想：我不想把这个仓库检出到本地。我离离开还有大概10分钟，但我必须把这个修改搞定，因为我们的CI坏了。结果我居然能够直接——我没有按Shift+点，但我做了——我只是把URL从`github.com`改成了`github.dev`。
But don't be like me. Jeff, don't listen to... Just because I do things this way, you should do things the way that Connor described. Use VS Code. Use Clang Tidal. Do all of those things do all of those good things don't be like me don't be like me i am i am a bad programmer which is why i mostly don't write code anymore yep c++ is awesome use a compiler explorer choose whatever book you want
它把我扔进了这个环境。我能够打开一个分支。我能够进行修改，而且——它的完成速度之快简直惊人。当时我就想：这就是我以后想写代码的方式。所以，是的。不过我只是偶尔用用VS Code。我日常首选的编辑器还是Vim。
i would also recommend check the show notes i'll'll add a list to the list of talks that the SG, was it 20? Whatever the education study group is for the C++ committee. They put together a list of top talks that cover different things. If it's not included, it definitely should be. Jason Turner has a talk that's like you know why i love c++ and it covers the 25 things that he really likes about it best talks when i was submitting for c++ north i was pleasantly surprised to notice that my talk was listed my c++ 17 features talk was listed as one of the like talks to like and you should your talks would aspire to
但别学我。杰夫，别听——仅仅因为我以这种方式做事，你应该以康纳描述的方式做事。用VS Code。用Clang Tidy。做所有这些事，做所有这些好事，别像我一样，别像我一样。我是一个糟糕的程序员，这就是为什么我基本上不再写代码了。是的，C++太棒了，去用编译器资源管理器，选择你喜欢的任何书吧。
be like this i'm like i kind of put that there for me well but in that talk like did not go great because i had syntax highlighting on my slides and the blues were too dark for people to read and like i had to like deal with that mid-talk i don't know how it came out on the recording, but that was rough. I think maybe I re-recorded because it was bad enough. I made them re-record it. Yep. CPP North. I mean, Call for Papers is closed,
我还建议看看节目shownotes，我会添加一个演讲列表，那是SG，是20号吗？不管C++委员会的哪个教育研究小组（education study group）是哪个。他们整理了一份涵盖不同主题的顶级演讲列表。如果还没包含在内，那绝对应该加进去。杰森·特纳有一个演讲，题目大概是“为什么我热爱C++”，其中涵盖了他真正最喜欢的25件事。当我为C++ North提交议题时，我惊喜地发现我的演讲被列入了——我的C++ 17特性演讲被列为了——那种“你应该让你的演讲去效仿”的榜样，我说我其实是把那个放那儿给自己的。好吧，但那个演讲结果并不是很好，因为我的幻灯片上有语法高亮，蓝色太深了，人们很难看清，我不得不中途处理这个问题。我不知道录音效果出来是怎样的，但那太糟糕了。我想我后来重新录制了，因为效果实在太差。我让他们重新录制了。是的。C++ North。我的意思是，论文征集已经截止了，
but I mean, nice try. Maybe next year at this point. But you still want people to go to your conference, right? That's true. That's true. That's true. I will true. That's true. I will probably have to start splicing in. You're going to throw a – so that conference is like the week of my birthday.
不过，我是说，祝你好运。也许下次赶上这时候吧。但你还是希望人们去参加你的会议，对吧？确实如此。确实如此。确实如此。我可能会开始穿插——你打算抛出一个——所以那个会议正好是我生日的那周。
So you're going to throw a ridiculous birthday party for me, right? Sounds good. Come to Toronto. You need to start planning that right now. Should I? We'll get Louie out from – Louie out. We'll get Michael out as well uh louie out we'll get michael out as well yeah no like yes you should be like you should be coordinating with my mother like you should be there's a lot of things you should be doing right here you have responsibilities sending the pigeons out to the
所以你要为我举办一个荒谬的生日派对，对吧？听起来不错。来多伦多吧。你现在就需要开始策划了。我是吗？我们要把路易（Louie）从——把路易请来。我们也要把迈克尔（Michael）请来，呃，把路易请来，我们也要把迈克尔请来，是的，不，就像，是的，你应该——你应该和我的母亲协调——你应该——有很多事情你现在就应该在做，你有责任，把信鸽派出去给
ducks to let them know to all come make sure that you're in town yeah so jeff i'm not sure if we really did a good job answering your question i feel like you did a good job of answering the question. Don't be like Bryce when it comes to programming, apparently. But yeah, I mean, C++ is a great language. A lot of great jobs out there. I mean, honestly, that's... One of the things he asked was how to get started. I legitimately think the best way to get started is to just do something.
鸭子们，让它们都知道，都要确保你在城里。是的。所以，杰夫，我不确定我们是否真的很好地回答了你的问题。我觉得你把这个问题回答得很好。在编程方面，千万别学布莱斯，显然。不过，是的，我的意思是，C++是一门伟大的语言。外面有很多很棒的工作。老实说，那就是——他问的其中一个问题是如何入门。我真心认为最好的入门方式就是直接去实践。
Do some project in C++. It doesn't really matter what. think the best way to get started is to just do something do some just dive in plus plus um doesn't really matter what um i feel like i feel like a lot of the times although it sounds like jeff's a pretty motivated person but a lot of the times when i get that question i'll get people like just randomly pinging me being like hey i'm interested in topic x like how do i get started and a lot of the times it's like just dive in. It doesn't matter what talk or what book or what pod. Find what you like, whether it's audio form or whether it's video lecture form or whether it's book form or whether it's just literally exploring the language and breaking things.
用C++做一个项目。其实是什么并不重要。我认为最好的入门方式就是直接去动手，做一些——直接一头扎进C++中，其实是什么并不重要。嗯，我觉得——我觉得很多时候，虽然听起来杰夫是个很有动力的人，但很多时候当我听到这个问题时，会有人随机发消息问我：嗨，我对主题X感兴趣——我该如何开始？很多时候答案就是：直接扎进去。不管是哪个演讲、哪本书、哪个播客都不重要。找到你喜欢的方式，无论是音频形式、视频讲座形式、书籍形式，还是字面意义上地探索语言并把它搞砸。
Find what method you like the best and just do that. The hardest part is putting the time in. I feel like people maybe get a mental block here because they think that becoming a C plus, like becoming a programmer or learning a C plus plus or learning any new like tech skill, they think that it's like becoming a lawyer. Like, you know, like what are the, what are the things, you know, that I have to do to become a lawyer? Like, you know, like there's like this one path that you have to go through and you have to go get into law school and then you have to do to become a lawyer. There's this one path that you have to go through and you have to go get into law school
找到你最喜欢的方法，然后去做。最难的部分是投入时间。我觉得人们在这里可能会有心理阻碍，因为他们认为成为一个C++——就像成为一个程序员、或学习C++、或学习任何新的科技技能，他们认为这就跟成为一名律师一样。就像，你知道的，就像，成为一名律师我必须做什么？就像，你知道的，存在这样一条你必须经历的唯一路径，你必须考入法学院，然后你必须去——成为一名律师，存在这样一条你必须经历的唯一路径，你必须考入法学院，
and then you have to get a law degree and then you have to pass a bar exam in the United States. It's like there's no certification for being a C++ programmer. And I would say there are some things that are like certifications or programs in tech. And I think some people think like, oh, well, I go do this and then I will be qualified because I'll have a piece of paper. And I think that's what trips people up.
然后你必须获得法学学位，然后在美国你必须通过律师资格考试。这就好像C++程序员并没有什么认证。而且我要说，在科技领域确实有一些类似于认证或项目的东西。我猜有些人会想，哦，好吧，我去完成这个，然后我就会具备资格，因为我会有一张纸。我认为正是这一点把人们绊倒了。
It's like that you're thinking that there's some fixed or set roadmap for you to get on like become a C++ programmer. There's not like, it's different for everybody. So the best way to get started is just, just, you know, figure out what's the way for you that you're going to learn, you know, figure out what interests you um there's no one fixed path for everybody to enter this you know this industry yeah yeah absolutely and that's the thing is like i i enjoy all forms i love lectures i love podcasts i love um reading actually is probably on the lowest on the list but like i absolutely love listening to podcasts like i listen to like i think at this point like 40 plus podcasts and um yeah cpp cast i think actually we're gonna have to keep track of this at some point we are gonna be the number two uh c++ podcast out there um currently right now it depends on how you define what a c++ podcast is because even us, we're like C++++, you know?
就像你认为存在某种固定或既定的路线图，可以让你踏上成为C++程序员的道路。根本没有——对每个人来说都是不同的。所以最好的入门方式就是，找出对你而言最有效的学习方式，找出让你感兴趣的东西。对每个人来说，进入这个——进入这个行业并没有一条固定不变的路径。是的，是的，绝对是这样，而且重点在于——我喜欢所有形式，我喜欢讲座，我喜欢播客，我喜欢——阅读其实大概排在清单的最末尾，但我绝对喜欢听播客——我听的——我想现在大约有40多个播客，而且，是的，CppCast，我想我们实际上在某个时刻必须记录下来，我们将成为第二大C++播客——目前来看，这取决于你如何定义什么是C++播客，因为甚至我们，我们也是C++，你知道的？
But like CppCast is definitely number one. And I think at the moment, CppChat is number two. We're going to overtake them. And if you count us – Coming for you. Yeah, if you count us as a C++ podcast, we're number three. And then – How are you ranked in terms of subscribers?
但像CppCast绝对是第一。而且目前来看，CppChat是第二。我们要超越他们。如果你把我们算作——为你们而来。是的，如果你把我们算作C++播客，我们是第三。然后——你们的订阅量排名如何？
It depends. But like on my app that I used, which is CastBox, I believe, it shows both the number of subscribers and the number of plays. And I sort of they both typically follow. If you're ahead of in terms of subscribers, you're typically ahead of in terms of views as well. That being said, so we already just tied CPP Chat on this app with 4,000 views. But they still have more subscribers. They've got 274. Don't unsubscribe from them. Subscribe to us. I'm kidding.
这得看情况。但在我使用的应用上，也就是CastBox，我相信它既显示订阅量，也显示播放量。而且它们通常是同步增长的。如果你在订阅量上领先，通常在观看次数上也会领先。话虽如此，所以我们刚刚在这个应用上追平了CppChat，都有4000次观看。但他们依然拥有更多的订阅者。他们有274个。别取消订阅他们。订阅我们。开玩笑的。
Don't unsubscribe from them lovely people. Yeah, they've got 274 and to us I'm kidding Don't unsubscribe from them Lovely people Yeah they've got 274 And we're at 162 But But our Our Our trajectory Our acceleration
别取消订阅他们这些可爱的人。是的，他们有274个，而我们有162个。但——但是我们的——我们的轨迹——我们的加速度
Yes yeah Is greater than theirs We've got a lot of momentum And also Momentum A lot of regularity In that We've never missed
是的，是的——比他们的要大。我们有很大的势头。而且还有势头——有很高的规律性，因为我们从没缺席过——
Also too Yeah we've never missed a Friday We're at what Episode 67 68 What would it take for us never missed a Friday. We're at what? Episode 67, 68? What would it take for us to miss a Friday? A pandemic didn't do it. Oh, yeah. Should we talk about tail end of this?
还有，是的，我们从没缺席过周五。我们到了第几期？第67集、第68集？我们要落下一期周五得发生什么？大流行都没能阻止我们。哦，是的。我们要聊聊这期的尾声吗？
All right. Jeff, I hope that answers your question. Thank you for putting up with us, Jeff. We love you. We love all of our listeners. We really do. It's still hard to believe that people want to listen to this. Yeah, I mean, we did really – we have a little bit fallen off of the wagon.
好了。杰夫，希望这回答了你的问题。谢谢你包容我们，杰夫。我们爱你。我们爱所有的听众。真的。人们居然想听这个，这至今让人难以置信。是的，我的意思是，我们确实真的——我们有点偏离正轨了。
Yeah, well, don't worry. Is that wagon? We can get back on the – no, wagon. Wagon. Wagon. Wagon. Wagon. Wagon.
好吧，别担心。那是正轨吗？我们可以回到正轨——不，正轨。正轨。正轨。正轨。正轨。正轨。
Wagon. Wagon. Wagon. say wagon wagon wagon wagon wagon wagon the problem is the problem is is that i'm just having too much fun now i'm sure i mean i've always i've always described it to people it's like this podcast is all is just about the bromance chemistry that we have uh have we mentioned stood reduce in like 10 episodes no uh we haven't but are we having a great time we should talk about we should talk about stood fold at some point okay all right we'll wrap it up all right we're having fun good content's coming to actually stop recording because this
旅行车。旅行车。旅行车。说旅行车旅行车旅行车旅行车旅行车旅行车，问题是，问题是，我现在玩得太开心了，我确信，我的意思是，我一直，我一直对别人形容，就像这个播客完全就是关于我们之间的兄弟情谊和化学反应，呃，我们有在过去的10集里提到过斯图·雷杜斯（Stood Redus）吗？没有，呃，我们没有，但我们过得开心吗？我们应该找个时间聊聊斯图·福尔德（Stood Fold），好吧，行吧，我们要结束了，好吧，我们玩得很开心，精彩的内容马上就要来了，实际上我要停止录音，因为这个
is this is how long have we How long have we been recording for? An hour and 45 minutes. I've been recording for an hour and 53, so I'm hitting the stop button. I'm hitting the stop button. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是，这个是，我们录了多久了？我们录了一个小时四十五分钟了。我录了一个小时五十三分钟了，所以我要按停止键了。我要按停止键了。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。